accueillir mon ami la fille de la car
les voies y va bahia une surprise
aujourd'hui j'entends responsable du
cirque pinder ça va il est pas mal
ouais les bruits bon euh je voudrais
commencer en ayant une pensée pour
bernard de la villardière après avoir
été attaqué par le spider man des
musulmans gilles verdez hier cyril a dit
ça à yagg séparé se sont intéressés aux
squatteurs
le nouveau cauchemar des propriétaires
et ils ont fait le record de saison 1
millions 5,1 millions 500 mille c'est ça
voilà donc voilà il devrait en prendre
confiance avant l'aïd est pas obligé de
parler d'islam pour faire de l'audience
1 je suis surtout dégoûté pour la
production de son émission depuis 15 ans
ils payent des billets d'avion pour
aller voir des prostituées au brésil des
djihadistes en syrie alors qu'ils font
le meilleur score avec des squatteurs à
noailles
vous avez aussi parlé des haches pays
les gens au potentiel habituel
regardez koné va on vous aime
alors vous vous êtes un petit garçon
parce que le sûr mais c'est aussi un
enfant juif et le sérieux à côté de moi
mais parce que lui les enfants lui voilà
on est des gosses c'est sûr dépasserait
donc on dit ta gueule kaunas des trucs
comme ça mais c'est le côté enfant et
vous vous êtes un gamin on vous adore
parce que vous êtes un gosse et puis les
autres vous déteste pour les mêmes
raisons envoyez le sauver c'est aussi et
c'est une gamine elle dans le film mais
c'est quoi cette nouvelle manie de
vouloir à détecter que son enfant est un
génie
les parents calmez-vous moi mes enfants
sont pas le potentiel déjà cessé mes
enfants surtout mon fils adam bellatin
qui regardent t'choupi en mangeant ses
crottes de nez qui commence fin son
repas par une mousse au chocolat
quelque chose me dit que ça sera pas le
prochain thomas pesquet juin
blanc s'est tendue en france en ce
moment le climat est quasi guerrier hier
les chroniqueurs ont vécu ça de très
près aujourd'hui nous allons revenir sur
la bataille du 3 mai c'est l'entretoit
cyril et jean michel blanquer
voici donc un nouveau numéro de babak
alips à 1 3 mai 2021
le général baba premier attaque le
commandant blanc caire chef d'état-major
de le ps et des sciences nat
la france retient son souffle comment en
est on arrivé là
c'est ce que nous allons vous raconter
dans ce nouveau numéro de ba baca lips
lundi matin paris s'éveille comme tous
les jours que des compliments est amorcé
alors les gens reprennent peu à peu leur
vie normale
personne ne s'attend à ce qui va se
passer et tout à coup en plein
après-midi à 16h36 le général baba
premier attaque le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
en bas de chez toi je quitte en ont mais
personne ne m'entend
juste un signe subira après le chant des
partisans
voici donc le chant des partisans un
livre de six violentes ont le pouvoir
que pour la chanson française est-ce que
tu m'entends et au est ce que tu me sens
et aux sept pas je suis là et en bon
état
c'est en alertant pris sous le feu des
balles le commandant blanc caire dans la
fuite
il part s'installer dans le seul pays où
il aura l'air sympa mur péquiste ans il
s'est tu
descendre dans la rue et lanceurs
seconde hostile
sur blanc qu'il ya moyen d'avoir la
moyenne là sous lieutenant marlène
schiappa réplique est les étudiants vous
êtes trop relou si vous continuez vous
copy-top jab une menace terrible
quelques heures plus tard dans son
quartier général de boulogne le général
baba convoque ses troupes
l'amiral morini-bosc connu pour avoir
triomphé à marignan le sergent castaldi
10e de lynx et le colonel pernikoff tout
juste débarqué de stalingrad pas la
ville la station de métro
à 20h38 d'abba reçoit les étudiants qui
sont déterminés comme jamais
j'ai commencé une grève de la faim
depuis ce matin et à 20h48
comment ce sétois jean michel blanquer
jean-michel à l'encré ne dit rien il
n'aurait pas là il est encore sûr pas à
18 heures alors oui il accompagnera les
deux sens c'est un brave à recevoir
recevoir c'est un succès j'ai bloqué
ridor aujourd'hui la vérité cette
bataille sera appelée lara sera de
l'atlantique
21h12 les pourparlers aboutissent
initial est ce que vous allez faire
quelque chose au pas je souhaite comme
un jour soit les organisations lycéennes
qui sont en sel supérieur de l'éducation
le lendemain l'armistice est signé leur
désaccord de yala avait comme arbitre la
présidente du syndicat étudiant ou un
jeune qui déclarent aux deux parties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]